c'est tout simplement complètement
hallucinant limite un peu flippant je
vous explique pas ce que
[Musique]
aujourd'hui un contenu différent de
d'habitude c'est une vidéo qui est dédié
uniquement à tous ceux et toutes celles
qui rencontrent des problèmes de
récupération de données pour leur disque
dur disque dur dans l'ordinateur disques
durs externes cartes microsd carte sd
clé usb
tout ce qui va être stockage en règle
générale et j'ai été contacté par la
société vonderscher qui m'a proposé une
vidéo sponsorisés pour parler de cette
thématique
je me suis dit pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
tout simplement alors déjà effectivement
parce qu'on finance un petit peu la
chaîne mais vous aurez pas fait ce
contenu si je trouvais pas en adéquation
avec une problématique que j'ai
rencontré moi j'ai rencontré plusieurs
fois ce problème c'est à dire avoir du
contenu que ce soit sur une clé usb ou
sur un disque dur du contenu plante est
irrécupérable
et là vous passez des heures à chercher
c'est souvent avant une présentation
importante
ou alors un document qu'elle vous tenez
ce soit des photos ou autre chose et
vous n'arrivez plus à mettre la main
dessus
là c'est la méga loose vous êtes
dégoûtés ça ça m'arrivait un paquet de
fois
donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas
partager ça avec vous alors la société
sylvander cher le logiciel s'est reco
bri qui vous montre un petit peu comment
ça marche
si vous êtes intéressé par cette
problématique et vous invite à visionner
toute la vidéo ça vous intéresse pas
vous donne rendez vous dès demain lire
mon avis ça pourrait vous sauver la vie
à un joueur vous invite à regarder quand
même
voilà comment ça se présente c'est un
logiciel pc mac vous pouvez télécharger
gratuitement il ya des fonctionnalités
payantes mais ya déjà pas mal de choses
à faire comme ça vous avez donc
plusieurs parties récupération de
fichiers supprimés
ça ça peut être super intéressant
lorsque vous avez des suppressions
occident pelle des pannes de courant
lorsque votre disque dur plante ça peut
quand même bien bien bien bien bien vous
sauver la vie sur du contenu vous
arrivez pas retrouvé récupération de
votre corbeille qui est vidé par erreur
elle récupère un petit peu ce qui
traînait dans ça ça paye bien
récupération de disques formatés ça
effectivement vous avez formater votre
disque et vous dites maintient donc
super importante dans là vous pouvez
retrouver récupération de partitions
perdu ça peut aussi être intéressant une
récupération universel à la si vraiment
ces bordels vous savez plus par où
passait vous pouvez passer par la
récupération des données d'un système
plante et why not peu intéressants
récupération de données ayant une
attaque de vie
vous avez un virus qui vous à bout vais
vous donner vous utilisez une recovery
tu es vous pour essayer de récupérer
vous donner sinon vous avez aussi
récupération de périphériques externes
alors ça ça peut être vraiment vraiment
vraiment intéressant je pense notamment
mois toutes les sauvegardes de la carte
mémoire
sauvegarde sur des clés usb disques durs
externes ça pour moi c'est une des
fonctions essentielles
moi en tout cas plusieurs fonctions
essentielles récupération de fichiers
supprimés ça c'est super important
récupération de corbeil ça peut vous
sauver la vie et tout ce qui va être un
périphérique externe ça c'est super
intéressant mais la récupération des
données citées une attaque de virus
c'est quand même relativement rare si ça
vous arrive
franchement là vous avez pas de bol ne
passez pas sous une échelle attention au
chat noir dans vous parce que là
franchement on vous êtes vraiment
poissard je pense que ces trois
points-là sont quand même les points
essentiels
je vous présente donc ma clé ma clé usb
on va la brancher et on va voir ce qu'on
peut récupérer là dessus ma clé usb est
bien connu si dans son titre donc
maintenant ce qu'on va faire on va
tenter une récupération universel ici à
partir du périphérique externe c'est ma
clé usb démarrer et là il va commencer à
pédaler pour récupérer les données qui
peuvent être récupérées c'est
intéressant que ce logiciel c'est que
dès lors vous donnez sont récupérables
rock aubry doit faire le job
donc c'est une solution qui est fiable
et qui ont plus de ça est assez rapide
et là je suis en train d' achat sur une
clé usb
ça mettra un peu plus de temps que si
vous êtes sur un disque dur un ssd ou
encore une carte micro sd qui carbure au
monde de recherche donne un taux de
réussite de 96 % ce qui dans l'absolu
est quand même relativement élevé ça
veut dire que les 4 % qui restent s'est
perdue c'est perdu c'est comme ça en
tout cas
lorsque vous êtes vraiment dans la
galère si vous récupérez 96% de données
vous remercierez et vous serez très
heureux
d'ailleurs c'est ce logiciel vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
dans la description pour aller le
télécharger
au bout de quelques minutes est réalisé
terminé et j'ai accès ici à plein
d'informations différentes à plein de
fichiers que j'avais directement à
l'intérieur et c'est vrai que tout ça je
pense est complètement l'avoir supprimé
son des vidéos des vieilleries
et oh j'ai pas mal de vieux trucs et
s'était complètement effacé ma clé usb
et là je les retrouve directement c'est
hallucinant après j'ai tout cas
navigation qui se fait ici au travers
des sous menus
j'ai donc les emplacements perdu avec
aussi des vieilles vidéos ça c'est
vieux-chais vieux la vache tous ces
vieux truc je peux récupérer tout ça
c'est vraiment tout simplement
hallucinant c'est tout simplement
complètement hallucinant et limite un
peu flippant je vous explique pas ce que
on peut imaginer vous avez votre clé usb
dans lequel vous avez supprimé tous les
fichiers vous voulez pas qu'un de vos
collègues quelqu'un de votre famille de
vos amis est taxée vous avez donc tout
supprimer pour être tranquille il suffit
donc de récupérer votre clé on le passe
dans le logiciel
et là on récupère tous vos vieux
fichiers vidéo photothèque document tout
est directement là c'est quand même un
petit peu flippant néanmoins le logiciel
marche super bien là je vous le montre
sur une clé usb c'est exactement la même
chose sur une carte micro sd sur un
disque dur sur un ordinateur sur ce que
vous voulez pour récupérer toutes vos
données et ça croyez moi ça pourrait
franchement vous sauver la vie
ce logiciel je vous le dis c'est
recovery fait part aux vendeurs cher si
vous intéresse vous avez un lien en bas
dans la description vous pouvez aller
voir d endettement est ce que vous avez
déjà eu des problèmes pour récupérer vos
données un disque dur qui a cramé une
clé usb qui ne marche plus mark et moi
tout ça directement en bas en
commentaire et dites moi comment vous
avez fait pour récupérer vous donner est
ce que vous avez réussi les récupérer et
est ce que vous pensez au final que ce
logiciel pourrait vous sauver la vie
j'entends bien vos commentaires d'ici là
soyez ça je vous embrasse portez vous
bien
[Musique]